Olá você costuma usar papel alumínio
para assar alimentos ou consome aqueles
alimentos enlatados com frequência e usa
panelas de alumínio na sua cozinha pior
você usa desodorantes comerciais os
chamados
antitranspirantes então cuidado preste
muita atenção no que eu vou informar
nesse vídeo aqui o Dr Alan Dutra médico
com mais de 25 anos de experiência e
hoje quero compartilhar com vocês uma
verdade um tanto quanto incômoda
mas que é extremamente importante o
problema é que o alumínio é silencioso e
se acumula no nosso corpo sem fazer
alarde e pode acabar trazendo um monte
de problemas de saúde Especialmente para
quem já tem uma certa sensibilidade no
estômago um intestino mais delicado ou
um fígado que já trabalha no limite este
elemento tem o potencial perigoso de se
infiltrar no nosso cérebro a abrindo
caminho para doenças neurológicas que
são devastadoras e também estando
Possivelmente envolvido na Gênese de
certos tipos de câncer na minha
experiência como médico a intoxicação
por alumínio é algo bem comum nos exames
dos pacientes é mais raro ver alguém com
níveis totalmente normais nesse metal do
que com níveis No Limite superior ou
elevados e às vezes esses níveis estão
bem altos mesmo isso me fez querer
chamar a atenção de todo mundo para o
quanto esse problema é sério sabe
pessoal é impressionante pensar que esse
metal alumínio é tão comum não é é o
terceiro elemento mais abundante na
crosta terrestre ele está no solo na
água no ar que a gente respira mas desde
a revolução industrial começamos a usar
o alumínio de um jeito que nossos
antepassados nem sonhariam antigamente a
exposição a alumínio era algo raro mas
mas hoje em dia vivemos na chamada era
do alumínio isso significa que ele não
está só por aí no ambiente natural Ele
está na comida que a gente come na água
que nós bebemos até nos produtos que a
gente passa na pele desde as embalagens
dos alimentos e bebidas até os
cosméticos como desodorante o alumínio
virou nosso companheiro perigoso de
todos os dias então fica a pergunta até
onde a gente vai por conveniência
sabendo que isso pode estar
comprometendo nossa saúde sabe quando a
gente fala sobre alumínio e saúde muitas
vezes não percebemos o quão longe os
efeitos desse metal podem ir começando
pelo cérebro os efeitos e sintomas do
Alumínio podem ser bem
assustadores por exemplo perda de
memória aquela sensação de estar com a
cabeça nas nuvens esquecer das coisas
mais mais simples e ter dificuldade para
se concentrar são alguns sintomas que
muita gente pode achar que é só Cansaço
ou estresse Mas podem ser sinais da
neurotoxicidade do Alumínio e isso afeta
tudo desde trabalhar até curtir momentos
simples com a família se você anda
sentindo o estômago meio estranho
inchaço digestão difícil ou constipação
pode ser mais uma pista de que o
alumínio está fazendo efeito and até
como o nosso intestino funciona e a pele
coceira manchas uma aspereza aqui uma
descamação ali podem ser mais do que
problemas de pele comuns podem ser o
alumínio dando sinais através da pele
dores pelo corpo queda de cabelo sentir
menos fome perder peso sem motivo
cansaço que não passa com nada parece
lista de sintomas de um monte de coisas
mas quando você junta tudo pode ser o
seu corpo falando que está intoxicado
por alumínio agora o que realmente faz a
gente parar para pensar É como esse
metal pode estar ligado a doenças bem
sérias como Alzheimer e demência e até
ser suspeito em caso de câncer autismo
depressão e outras condições como
insônia ansiedade e aquela fadiga que
parece que nunca vai embora bom pessoal
quando o alumínio chega no nosso corpo
ele pode mexer com as células de um
jeito bem sério Imagine as células como
pequenas casas que usam eletricidade
para funcionar o alumínio pode bagunçar
essa eletricidade Especialmente nos
interruptores que controlam a entrada e
saída de informações e energia isso vai
afetar desde a forma como as células se
comunicam até como o corpo responde
hormônios neurotransmissores que são
importantes na comunicação entre os
neurônios as células do cérebro
e até da insulina que controla o açúcar
do sangue então esse problema é bem
maior do que a gente imagina maior até
do que outros tipos de toxinas que já
conhecemos isso mostra o quanto é
importante a gente ficar de olho e
entender os riscos que o alumínio traz
pra nossa saúde e não para por aí o
alumínio também bagunça a absorção de
coisas super importantes pro nosso
organismo como selênio esse mineral que
é essencial para manter a nossa saúde e
nos proteger de doenças e também o
fósforo outro mineral que precisamos
para várias funções do corpo e como é
que o alumínio causa todos esses
problemas o intestino quando saudável e
quando sua barreira está íntegra serve
como um escudo protetor minimizando a
absorção de substâncias nocivas como o
alumínio cont tudo um intestino hiper
permeável o intestino que vaza o liqu
gut
ele está com a sua parede danificada e
com Buraquinhos e pode facilitar a
entrada de alumínio e outras toxinas na
nossa corrente sanguínea exacerbando os
efeitos nocivos em nosso corpo incluindo
o potencial acúmulo em órgãos vitais com
o cérebro Imaginem só o alumínio tem a
capacidade de passar por duas das
Barreiras mais importantes do corpo a
barreira intestinal e a barreira
hematoencefálica ou
pessoal a barreira hematoencefálica é
como um porteiro super rigoroso que só
deixa passar o que é realmente seguro
pro cérebro mas o alumínio consegue
passar por ela e vai se acumulando com o
tempo dentro do cérebro isso Começou a
chamar atenção dos cientistas que
decidiram investigar melhor o que isso
poderia significar paraa nossa saúde o
que eles descobriram é algo que a gente
precisa levar a sério altas doses de
alumínio no nosso cérebro podem causar
uma série de problemas desde efeitos
neurotóxicos até distúrbios no nosso
comportamento e isso tudo sem que haja
lesões visíveis no cérebro pessoal tem
estudos mostrando que até uma pequena
quantidade de alumínio pode ser tóxica
para o cérebro indicando que esse metal
não é só um risco a mais para a saúde
todos mas pode ser um dos vilões por
trás do Alzheimer uma pesquisa até
mostrou que quanto mais alumínio tem no
cérebro de uma pessoa mais grave podem
ser os sintomas da doença de alzheimer
Além de sua conexão com Alzheimer temos
que ter atenção especial para o papel do
alumínio em outras doenças cerebrais
como paxon e várias outras condições
neurológicas mas o impacto do Alumínio
vai além do cérebro existem estudos que
mostram que ele pode mexer também bem
com os nossos ossos contribuindo para
problemas óseos há indicações sugerindo
uma ligação entre o alumínio e
distúrbios alimentares como anorexia
além de poder afetar o sangue
prejudicando o transporte de oxigênio e
nutrientes vitais pelo corpo a questão
do Alumínio é sua possível relação com
câncer especialmente o câncer de mama é
algo que não podemos ignorar mesmo que
as pesquisas ainda não tenham chegado a
um consenso definitivo há estudos e
observações que nos fazem levantar a
sobrancelha ficar desconfiados o aumento
nos casos de câncer de mama é alarmante
e parece estar ligado a uma variedade de
fatores e nesse amanhado de causas
possíveis o alumínio que é um
ingrediente comum em cosméticos como os
desodorantes e também nos
antitranspirantes surge como suspeito
esses produtos que contêm composto de
alumínio para bloquear a transpiração
são usados diretamente em uma área cheia
de gânglios linfáticos e próxima aos
seios o que naturalmente nos faz
questionar se são realmente Seguros e
muitos dos nódulos nos seios aparecem
nas áreas mais próximas das axilas há
indícios de que o alumínio pode
interferir na forma como o DNA se repara
e até provocar ações processos
conhecidos Por estarem relacionados ao
desenvolvimento do Câncer diante dessas
incertezas adotar uma postura cautelosa
faz todo sentido pessoal e como a gente
pode reduzir essa exposição no dia a dia
começando pelas coisas que usamos todo
santo dia se você descobriu que o seu
desodorante preferido tem alumínio Que
tal buscar uma marca que não US esse
metal ou quem sabe testar fazer o seu
próprio desodorante com receitas
naturais que a gente acha fácil na
Internet tem muita opção bacana por aí e
na cozinha então talvez seja hora de dar
uma geral nos utensílios sab que
cozinhar com panelas e formas de
alumínio especialmente com comidas
ácidas é um jeito preocupante de se
expor a mais alumínio ainda pois é mas a
gente tem saída trocar por utensílios de
vidro cerâmica ou ácido inoxidável pode
ajudar a cortar a exposição direta e na
hora de assar vamos deixar o papel
alumínio de lado e optar por formas de
vidro e de preferência utilizando o
método de cozimento mais lento outra
verdade é que quem come comida direto
nessas embalagens de alumínio de marmita
acaba se expondo mais ao alumínio do que
quem usa prato normal e falando as
comidas melhor sempre uns alimentos
frescos aros em latados e ultra
processados evite ao máximo bebidas e
comidas em latas de alumínio
refrigerantes sucos cervejas aquele
leitinho ou achocolatado na latinha Ok e
fique de olho até nos fermentos químicos
de bolo e naqueles temperinhos prontos
porque eles podem ter alumínio na
composição ah e não é só na cozinha que
o alumínio aparece não ele está nos
cosméticos nas tinturas de cabelo e atém
alguns remédios como os antiácidos e os
remédios de diarreia sem falar nas
cápsulas de café daquelas máquinas
modernas e olha para quem tem Bebê e
Criança pequena em casa é bom saber que
altas doses de alumínio podem afetar o
desenvolvimento dos pequenos desde
reflexos até a capacidade de aprender na
infância um problema polêmico é que
parte significativa da exposição resulta
das vacinas recomendadas pelos órgãos
oficiais de saúde então por isso devemos
evitar ao máximo as outras Exposições
externas Ok então a dica de ouro é Vamos
ler os rótulos com mais atenção escolher
produtos mais saudáveis e seguros tanto
paraa nossa pele cabelo quanto o que
ingerimos Mas e aí além de evitar o que
mais podemos fazer bom limpar o
organismo é um bom começo fazer um detox
suave focando uma alimentação limpa é
fundamental a Afinal o intestino
saudável é nossa primeira linha de
defesa contra o alumínio que insiste em
entrar e para ajudar nesse detox queit
algumas ervas ricas em silício como o
coentro e a cavalinha elas são incríveis
para ajudar a limpar nosso corpo desse
metal incluir limão e vinagre de maçã na
dieta também é uma boa pois eles têm
aquela capacidade maravilhosa de
mobilizar o alumínio para fora do nosso
sistema eu vou deixar na descrição o
link de um vídeo super top sobre como
fazer um detox suave Obrigado por
assistir esse vídeo Espero que essas
informações compartilhadas aqui com
vocês inspirem a fazer escolhas
conscientes sobre a sua exposição ao
alumínio e a priorizar sua saúde e
bem-estar muito obrigado pela sua
atenção um grande abraço um beijo no seu
coração e você é
Vera